it looked like it looked like
Philip DeFranco was going to potentially
be joining us I sent an invite and I
don't know he said he just needed to
record a promo and then he would join us
live which would be great to catch up
with Philly D
but I don't know where he went or how to
get him back on I see Ali Cat's Corner
asking about Doug mastriano I think he's
disgusting I mean I think listen if
mastriano defeats Shapiro and becomes
the governor of Pennsylvania
uh 2024 gets extraordinarily dangerous
extraordinarily dangerous because he
will try to steal the electoral votes in
Pennsylvania if a Democrat wins it's
that simple
it's that simple he will try to steal it
and so
um it is that's a really we're watching
that race really closely obviously we're
watching DeSantis Christian Florida
although DeSantis looks like he's going
to easily win
um and I'm trying to think you know Oz
fetterman were watching deming's Rubio
is interesting Beto and um
um Abbott although Abbott is winning
right now there's so many important
races so many different important races
uh all right let's see if Philly D is
ready to go here and see if he will join
us that would be very very interesting
um and in the meantime
oh hold on is Philly D joining us let's
see
A lot happened
Philly D
ude here we go one sec I've never
actually Gone live
look at this guy
how are you doing I'm lagging I'm sorry
oh my God are you you're shooting in
promos
no I was I uh the show just went up my
brain's dead so if you are looking for
any sort of
uh meaningful good conversation for me
it might not happen but I decided no no
no no I would never I would never go to
you for that
but yeah no but I had to come in and say
that I'm a fan so that uh some right
Wingers can hate on me for it listen we
I'm oh I the the feeling is mutual here
was the one thing I wanted to ask you
because I don't know if you know the
financial guy ramit Sefi do you know
this guy who wrote the book I will teach
you to be rich
no okay really good Financial writer and
on Twitter lately he's been lighting up
the right Wingers and all these people
are like I used to like you until you
became political and all this different
stuff my memory of you is you used to be
way less political in the earlier days
of your YouTube stardom which I think is
absolutely the right term to use and it
seems now like you're sort of uh letting
it Loose a little bit and just dealing
with dealing with the repercussions of
people who don't like your opinions well
I would say uh in 2016 I definitely
finally got to to be political because
you know uh Clinton and Trump made
everyone interested in politics for a
little bit and then everyone even if
they don't want to be interested over
the next four years after that had to be
um but yeah I think uh until 27
oh and he's gone right
right in the middle of a story let's see
if we can get him back that was nuts I
don't even know what happened there
he just bailed it was right in the
middle of 2017 something happened and
then Philly bailed
dear God uh
man
that's crazy
well that's too bad Phil just bailed
I think I could fill in the blanks in
2017 he decided to let it all hang out